thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
good afternoon I'm Patty Brennan I'm the
director of the National Library of
Medicine before I give you my welcome I
would like to take a moment and
congratulate Donnie Bliss and all that
worked on this wonderful film it was
terrific thank you very much
we're indeed delighted to have you here
this afternoon and I wish to bring
greetings to those of you who are here
in the room with us at the lipsid
auditorium the nlm leadership NIH
colleagues and those from visitors from
outside of the fence we thank you for
coming through I also bring greetings to
those of you who are listening on the
live stream and we thank NIH and the CIT
to for the opportunity to broadcast this
and those of you listening in the future
to our words from this afternoon of June
the 13th July the 13th excuse me
um the National Library of Medicine has
a rich and long history dating from a
few books on a shelf in an army surgeon
general's office to what we have today a
global Enterprise reaching everywhere in
the world and in the future into space
this book that we're here to celebrate
today comes in an important time for the
National Library of Medicine it marks
that our history it documents our past
and it provides us with a foundation for
our future with the book it was the
combined effort of many people but
particularly Jeff Resnick and Ken Coyle
who you'll be hearing from this
afternoon I'm working with our
colleagues around the library we not
only had this book available in a
physical form but it's available online
at the website you see here the entire
book is available for free download and
the images are also available at this
website through the the book is
available through the nlm digital
collection series now the National
Library of Medicine is currently
developing a new strategic plan we do
this about every 10 years and since this
decade has passed we've had a chance to
reflect on what has happened over the
last 10 years and where we need to be
going because in just about 20 years
we'll be celebrating our Bicentennial
and hitting our third Century over the
last 10 years we've seen new things come
about the iPhone came about advances of
biomedical informatics we now have data
science We Believe Precision medicine
will be a key to the Future open access
to the biomedical literature around the
world and fundamental changes to our
countries and the world's health and
Health Care Systems all of these
challenges and changes offer new
directions for a library a new
opportunity for scientific advancement
we as the world's largest biomedical
Library the collection of literature
from around the world we house a
significant amount of data resources as
well as literature-based resources and
we have the infrastructure to make these
available globally and worldwide the
opportunities that are available now
must be seized by the National Library
of Medicine to continue to accelerate
both Discovery and progress in
biomedical research and in the care of
Everyday People we are committed to
building the data infrastructure that
will support the future of biomedical
research and health for all
as we celebrate and into the present and
anticipate our future and look to
achieve success in our strategic
planning process we need to build on our
history now that you forget it nor to be
held hostage by it this new book helps
us to do all of this we can recall and
build important accomplishments and
challenges of our predecessors and
remember that change in Innovation have
always been a part of the library
they're not new to us now
Beyond being a product of scholarly
effort which is one of the major
contributions of a research intensive
environments such as ours and the
expertise of our outstanding staff this
book helps to document the expertise of
generations of Library staff who face
the challenges in their day to bring
literature and information into the
hands of its patrons and also to grow
the institution to what it is today and
laying a foundation for where we can be
in the in the future what we have here
is the perfect Exemplar of what the
National Library of Medicine is about
scholarship and promoting access to our
resources through Outreach the book
illustrates so much over the long period
that it covers and you'll see when you
download your own copy you can learn
about the aspects of the library that
may have puzzled you what is that
rooftop looking in that strange shape
for us what's it really supposed to be
do I learned from This Book You'll also
get to meet my sister who was in that
photograph of me for my swearing-in
which I'm delighted to see but the book
is most important because it illustrates
the people and the place as with the
form the history of the National Library
of Medicine books and journals are
important but the delivery of those
books and journals requires a creative
mind of our entire staff I want to thank
all of the staff specifically from the
history of medicine division who were
involved in crafting the book and making
it publicly available to all for
appreciating it and also at a time
that's so important for our institution
we have to teach the world it's not your
mother's Library anymore and this book
will show your past and take us there
please consider opening it up please add
it to your summer reading list please
enjoy and take forward the message of
the National Library of Medicine and our
great history I'm now going to turn this
meeting over to Dr Resnick who is the
director of our history of medicine
division Jeff and his group will be
offering perspectives on the book
explaining some of our history and
inviting you into think about our future
thank you very much for being here Jeff
thank you very much Patty and thank you
for coming this afternoon and being
supportive of this project
I also want to join Patty in thanking
our colleague Don Bliss for the great
production that introduced our
proceedings this afternoon Don it's
great to work with you and thank you
very much for your creativity and your
dedication to that production it's
wonderful
I also want to thank everyone here today
and everyone watching remotely it's a
pleasure to welcome you to this
symposium
and to recognize the publication of this
new book and its free availability as
Patty said in all of the images in it
through our nlm digital collections
Repository
this program is part of the lecture
series of the nlm's history of medicine
division which promotes awareness and
use of nlm and other historical
collections for research education and
public service in biomedicine the social
sciences and the humanities the series
also supports the commitment of the nlm
to recognizing and celebrating diversity
all of our lectures are free and open to
the public and all of our lectures are
now a privileged to say are live
streamed and archived by NIH video
casting this is a public service made
possible through a generous gift to the
nlm from the Michael E DeBakey
foundation and we're certainly grateful
to the DeBakey foundation for the
support which benefits so many today and
will in the future as many more see
these archive proceedings
so every book begins with an idea
this book began with several ideas which
combined to shape its development and
its purpose the first idea involved
responding to a problem addressing a
need and really seizing an opportunity
and all at a time of great change for
our Institution
the problem was that many people who I
met in the course of my work and many
that my colleagues met also were
familiar with one or more aspects of the
nlm which was great but too few were
aware of the history of the library and
the fact that it was nearly two
centuries old occupied multiple
locations in the DC area and could claim
a history informed by major events that
were familiar to all of us the U.S Civil
War the world wars the Cold War and the
information age of the 1960s and 1970s
this lack of awareness about the history
of the library was compounded by several
realities
visitors who I and my colleagues welcome
to the library wondered how the nlm
became a part of the NIH they wondered
how it came to occupy such a distinctive
building which Patty referred to and
where its historical collections came
from many individuals who of any
individuals have written about the
library and addressed some of these
questions but none of these Publications
were or are really intended for a
general audience none of them
represented really an accessible public
history of a public institution which
traces its Origins to the early 19th
century
such a public history it seemed to me
needed to inform as well as to inspire
it needed to connect our institution to
familiar historical events events which
did inform the history of our
Institution
and such a public history needed to
acknowledge both the leaders and the
staff of the library all told really
thousands of individuals who over the
course of nearly two centuries built the
library into what it is today and what
it will become in the future
framed in these ways such an accessible
public history could not really be
all-encompassing or comprehensive but
rather it needed to be a general one
which could be appreciated by readers of
all ages and all backgrounds the public
if you will it needed to draw these
individuals in to learning more about
our Institution
through the bibliography that appears at
the end of the book which lists freely
available resources themselves and
otherwise by visiting us online and
visiting us physically here on the NIH
campus for a tour or in fact to conduct
research in our world-renowned
collections which span 10 centuries and
come from nearly every part of the globe
in such a public history I and my
colleagues believed needed to be
publicly available and more on that in
just a moment
so the need to craft a public history of
the library became clear and so was the
opportunity to undertake this project
with colleagues from around our
institution not only in the history
medicine division of the library but but
in other parts of the library as well by
drawing on our Collective expertise and
on our Rich image Collections and along
the way perhaps we might even seek out
images from other institutions that
could help us tell our story and in fact
we did that we'll talk about that later
so this was the book we envisioned and
after some very careful research some
careful writing and a lot of editing and
a lot of collaboration this is the book
that we've achieved it could not have
been possible in the first place if our
predecessors did not in fact document
their work and preserve it for our
Discovery our inspiration and our work
together as we build on the achievements
of the past face new challenges and
overcome these new challenges to build
and sustain an Ever greater National
Library of Medicine
moreover this book would not have been
possible without the current generation
of Library staff who lent their
expertise in such great ways rightly so
we've dedicated this book to the current
staff of the library to their
predecessors our predecessors and to all
who will come after us who will serve in
this institution who will serve the
nation and in fact the world from their
home here on the NIH campus thanks are
especially due to my colleague and
co-author and co-editor Ken Coyle and to
our chapter authors Steve Greenberg
James labasheer and rothfeld and Susan
speaker and to our colleagues Jenny Roth
who's curator of nlm's prints and
photographs collection Doug Atkins
technician for the collection and Kendra
irigby our pathway student who worked
diligently in the collection during the
course of her time with us from the
middle of 2015 until earlier this year
Jenny Doug and Kendra worked together to
produce scans of the wonderful images
that you'll see in our book and they
deserve much credit for this outstanding
work
additionally our colleague Steve
Greenberg deserves thanks for his own
outstanding new photography of key
subjects and key items which are
depicted in the book and discussed by
the chapter authors and many more
colleagues are named in the
acknowledgments of our book and I urge
you to read those acknowledgments
carefully because all of these
colleagues deserve the credit in which
that we convey to them and I want to
take this moment publicly to thank every
one of the people who are acknowledged
in our acknowledgments for everything
they did to help make this book possible
it's also important to add that this
book we envisioned in the first place
could not become a reality without a
publisher
there are few who publish books of these
kinds one of the best known in the field
is Arcadia publishing of Charleston
South Carolina I proposed our book idea
to them hoping they would consider it
for their popular images of America's
series and I proposed it to them with a
substantial expectation
which I hope that and really really hope
that they would accept that expectation
was that The Complete Book would be made
freely available by the nlm itself
available to anyone around the world who
would wish to read it
well I held my breath as I waited
Arcadia's review of my request as part
of the larger proposal of the book about
a week later I received a call from our
commissioning editor who indicated that
the Press was thrilled with the project
and would be happy to accommodate the
request
this was great news and it's great news
today that this public history of our
public institution is in fact publicly
available for all to appreciate it
really is a great public-private
partnership that we've achieved together
I'm really proud of this book and the
research writing and editing that went
on to support it I'm really honored to
be able to work this way with my
colleagues and I again thank all of them
and I'm really proud of the public
service that this book represents
spanning not only the recent history of
our institution but over the course of
two centuries and it appears at an
exciting time for the library as Paddy
conveyed as we all look ahead embrace
our Dynamic history and recognize that
it is dynamic and as such we should find
inspiration in this history and not be
constrained by it
it's my pleasure now to introduce three
of my colleagues who contributed to this
new book and who will offer perspectives
on their contributions following their
presentations will take questions as
part of a panel discussion and we
welcome questions from everyone here at
lipset Auditorium and those of you who
are watching online and following via
Twitter at nlm his talk
in order of their presentations Ken
Coyle is Deputy Chief of the nlm's
history of medicine division Dr Steve
Greenberg is head of our rare books and
early manuscript section in the division
and Susan speaker is a historian in our
division in the digital manuscripts
program our first speaker will be Ken
Coyle and again I want to thank Patty
for her wonderful introduction and thank
all of you here and out there for
watching and listening Ken
foreign
thank you Jeff and uh I'd like to Echo
Jeff's uh thanks to Dr Brennan for her
support of this uh this project from the
beginning
um
this has been a very interesting project
to work on for a number of reasons uh
first of all
from the onset we wanted to
approach this as a general audience
history not a scholarly work that only
other historians would be interested in
uh so that meant that we did all the
same research that we would do for a
larger more scholarly work but then we
had to pair it down to short concise
chapters that highlighted the
significant stories and events from our
history without drowning the reader in
minutia
and second This was meant from the start
to be an illustrated history pulling
primarily from the rich uh collection of
prints and photographs at the National
Library of Medicine this meant that the
images drove the narrative to some
extent which was especially significant
for the early chapters like mine where
there weren't a lot of images available
from those time periods
uh we did
focus on the images but we didn't allow
the images to derail or skew the overall
history but it did make us think about
how the images could tell the story that
we wanted and needed to tell
we are of course a library and in fact
we're the biggest library of Our Kind in
the world and so to a great extent our
history is documented in our own
collections however we discovered while
researching this book
that other institutions held a handful
of documents and images about us that we
don't have in our own collections in
some cases this was because people who
were involved in the library's history
donated their papers to different
institutions like maybe their alma mater
uh in other cases another institution
with an intertwined history such as the
Smithsonian or the national museum of
health and Medicine had unique materials
about our shared past and in one
particular case it was because the
document in question predates our own
library's history
on our own library's collections
so
uh
we knew that in early 1956 Senators
listers Hill Listerhill and John F
Kennedy introduced legislation to rename
the Armed Forces Medical Library as the
National Library of Medicine and to Move
It from the Department of Defense to the
Public Health Service
we had this legislation in our
collections it's freely available it's
mentioned in chapter five of our book
but as I argued in the book and as
others have argued before me we have a
legitimate claim to much deeper Roots
than this 1956 name change
we knew there was an 1836 document
requesting funds for books in the
collections of the National Archives we
knew about this document because of a
footnote in the 1982 nlm history by
Windham miles but really that's about
all we knew regarding that document
I was quite surprised to learn that nlm
didn't have a copy of that document in
our collections nor did we even know the
exact nature of the document and
interestingly the same document had
apparently been used by Colonel Edgar
Hume who was the the head librarian in
the 1930s to establish the library's
birth date and justify a centennial
celebration in 1936 100 years after this
document was written but apparently he
and his colleagues at the time did not
see the value in retaining a copy of it
so I wanted to remedy this and I wanted
to get a copy of this document for our
collections so I went to Nara on a quest
to find our origin document
now finding this document was akin to a
genealogist finding the name of a
long-lost ancestor on a ship's registry
or an immigration document it was no
easy task the surgeon general's records
at Nara although they're all in the same
record group record group 112. they're
organized in countless volumes of
sub-categorized handwritten
correspondence books most of which exist
only in a single copy they have not been
transcribed or digitized or microfilmed
and worst of all the subcategories have
titles similar enough to make searching
for a specific document
a frustrating guessing game so for
example there's a series called letters
and endorsement sent another called
letters and endorsements received and
another that's just called
correspondence
so I spent a day at Nara and I was
ecstatic to find the budget estimate
from November 12 1836.
that included the first request for
funding for books for 150 which you can
see down at the uh the the bottom of
this the the document pictured on the
screen there that was the first time
that funding was requested from the
government to buy books specifically to
build a library for the Surgeon General
so I took pictures of the document and I
went back to the office satisfied that I
had succeeded in my quest
unfortunately I'm not much of a
photographer and the pictures that I
took were not of the quality necessary
for either the book or for our digital
collections so it was determined that we
needed to send a real photographer Dr
Stephen Greenberg back to Nara to get
usable images of the document so I gave
Steve my notes about where I had found
it
and he proceeded to naira where he spent
a whole day retracing my steps because
even though I gave him the exact terms
that I put on my pull slip when I went
the books that they pulled for him were
not the same as the books that they had
pulled for me when I had gone to do the
research So eventually he found it
thanks to his skill as both a researcher
and a photographer you can see the
document uh on the screen in front of
you and on page 13 of the book and it's
also in our digital Collections and uh
this is the type of of team effort and
collaboration that we depended on
throughout the process to make this book
a reality so I'm very grateful to to Dr
Greenberg for his help with that
now another aspect of this project that
proved challenging uh
was the selection and prioritization of
the content
as co-editors the final decision about
what went into the book fell to Jeff and
me but each of the authors had to start
with their own Corpus of research and
then boil it down to submit a concise
draft that met our Publishers guidelines
historians always have to Grapple with
decisions about what to include in their
writings and what to Omit inevitably
when researching a topic you'll run
across a story or event that catches
your attention and maybe even pulls you
away from the task at hand and the work
that you're supposed to be doing because
you're so fascinated by it
but you can't include everything in the
book especially a book like this one
that's intended to be this type of book
instead of this type of book something
that's intended to be kind of a light
read
and so you have to set it aside and move
on
so one such subject in my research for
this book was the meteorological
registers very dry reading as you might
guess by the by the name
but also fascinating in the context of
today's emphasis on data science because
it represents an early systematic effort
to gather and publish data prospectively
rather than retrospectively
so
in these meteorological registers here
we have young Surgeon General Joseph
Lovell
that's a picture of him there around
1820 think about that time frame Lewis
and the Lewis and Clark expedition is
still fresh in everybody's memory this
is years before the term Manifest
Destiny was coined and Lovell recognized
that the inevitable westward expansion
of American cities was going to provide
a singular opportunity to observe and
document the impact of that expansion on
the natural environment
he theorized that deforestation
population increases and the growth of
cities would impact average temperatures
and climate and he set up a system to
gather longitudinal data to measure
these impacts and thanks to Joseph
lovell's foresight we can now look at
two centuries of climate data to see the
direct impact of civilization
in addition these studies formed the
foundation of today's meteorological
science Paving the way for accurate
weather forecasting now the book covers
the meteorological registers and half a
paragraph and two images
but obviously there's a bigger story to
tell about this subject and about
countless others that we touch on
throughout the book
maybe we'll go back and develop our
Research into articles blog posts
presentations
and expand the research in other ways or
maybe the book will inspire someone else
to pick up these threads and weave a
whole new story
we're just happy to introduce readers to
these interesting little nuggets from
our library's history and we hope that
the book will serve as fodder for many
conversations in the future
so with that and with gratitude for the
opportunity to speak to you today and
the opportunity to work on this book
I'll turn it over to Dr Stephen
Greenberg
the head of our rare books and early
manuscript section Dr Greenberg
[Applause]
so why did you jump ahead a considerable
period of time to the 1930s
at which point the library had its first
custom built as a library home the
building we call the old red brick at
the lower left
the old red brick was kind of worn down
a little bit by the 1930s and Susan
speaker will be telling you more about
that in a moment
but the bottom line is the library in
the 1930s had problems
first of all there was this depression
going on and it affected us at the
library as much as anyone else
the building as I said was old it was
housing both the Army Medical Library
and the museum
space was at a premium there was simply
no more room at the end
and there was a staff issue because this
half had never been large but as the
1930s progressed and it became clear
that there were bad things brewing in
Europe
much of the staff were serving army
officers they were not permanent
employees at the library it was a
posting and they wished to go back to
more active positions in the field
so right after the centenary
celebration that Ken has just mentioned
we got a new director
Harold Wellington Jones that's Dr Jones
in the upper left an army Doctor Who
liked books that was kind of the
qualification to be director of the
library to that point
he came to the library in 1936 expecting
to spend four years at the library as a
standard posting that's what you did
but the years between 1936 and 1940 made
it very clear that this was not a time
to start switching directors
and so in 1940 the point when Dr Jones
Not only would have left the library but
also would have been ready for
retirement
he agreed to stay long and he in fact
stayed at the library until 1945.
and one of the immediate issues that
came up
and this really comes to the fore in
1940 is that war had broken out in
Europe and War was expected to spread
and sooner or later the United States
would become involved
and in December of 1940 a full year
before Pearl Harbor in the U.S entry
into the war
the librarian of Congress Archibald
mcleish contacted Dr Jones and also
curators at other culturally historical
sites in the D.C area and said folks
make plans
now it sounds a little weird that they
were thinking of German submarines
sailing up the Potomac and setting fire
to Washington
but remember now this is December of
1940.
France had fallen
Europe except for England was under the
control of the Nazis
the Battle of Britain had been raging
and London was being bombed on a daily
basis through the summer of 1940 there
was a lapse in October of 1940 because
of the weather but everyone expected
this to start over again
in the spring of 1941
so this is not as far-fetched then as it
might seem to us now
and collections were seen as being at
risk
so plans were made to move what is now
the history of medicine division to
Cleveland to the Allen Memorial Library
and you see the Allen library in your
upper right
and beginning in 1942
952 cartons weighing 75 tons of books
were transferred to Cleveland
where in fact they remained until the
current building was opened in 1962.
and for those of you who have heard my
tours and I give a lot of them I often
say well I guess they were sure by 62
the Germans weren't coming
now another thing that they were able to
do was to hire a staff to
deal with historical materials that the
library had and I want to bring to your
attention if I can find the the
lightsaber here
oh there it is
I want to play retention to this lady
over here that is Dorothy Julian
and more about Dr shui in a moment
but I also want to show you something
that we were able to do in Cleveland
that we sent we didn't have the room to
do in DC and that is
extensive rebinding of some of our
historical materials
now
this is the 1940s state of the art book
preservation was very different then you
took a book you put it in a sturdy
binding and you put it back on the Shelf
you would never do that now
or if you did you would do it only if
the binding was in really terrible
condition
like this one here this is not a modern
picture
this is a picture of one of the books it
was slated to be Rebound in 1942.
a binary was established that is John
eschman up there a world-renowned
bookminder
trained in Europe who happened to be
living in Cleveland at the time and he
was hired to set up the bindery
and you can see this is a modern picture
of some of the history of medicine
division books in The Cleveland
bindings there they're easy to recognize
because they're all basically
identically bound different color
leather they'll say Army Medical Library
down here on the heel
and one of the the card tricks I get to
play is I can look at that book and I
can say that I know it was bound between
1942 or really 43 when the bindery
opened in 1947 because after 47 they
start to say Armed Forces Medical
Library down on the heel so that's quote
it means your friends
the interesting thing though that Dr
shullian did and she was hired to work
at the Cleveland branch in 1944 and was
one of our most skilled bibliographers
if you've ever done any bibliographic
work with our earliest books you'll know
that our bibliography of in Canada those
printed books between 14 1501 was edited
by Dorothy Julian and it still is a
quoted standard throughout the world
Dr Julian would take the discarded old
book bindings the stuff that looked like
this
once they've been taken off the book she
took them home and she soaked them apart
in her bathtub in Cleveland
because back in the early days of
printing and binding you would take
scraps of waste paper
and stick them between the leather of
the binding and the wood of the board
they were called binders waste
she soaked the bindings apart was able
to rescue some of those bits and scraps
and these this is a recent picture of
some of the stuff that she found
we have it in hmd we have cataloged it
based on the book that it came from and
it's searchable in our online catalog
under the term backed up collection
I'm kind of moving ahead ever so
slightly so the red brick building was
seen as
worn out
well before the war and Jones knew this
and the Army knew that the library was
not meeting the standards that it wanted
to be because it was kind of a war on
and the
requirements for the library had
increased dramatically without there was
an increase in staff but it wasn't a
professional staff
and Jones knew this
and so he hired
with money from the Rockefeller
Foundation a team of Library
professionals from the American Library
Association
they worked in DC they sent a person out
to Cleveland to talk to the Cleveland
staff including Dr Julian
and they produced a report
which was done in the middle of the war
so even in 1943 when the out you know
outcome of the war was by no means
certain Jones is planning ahead and
obviously the team recommended a new
building which obviously did not happen
at that point but also
professionalization of the staff because
we had very few people with professional
Library degrees
largely army officers and clerical
and
Jones took the report
and used it to make plans he retired in
45 as I said there was a little bit of
reorganization and some people sort of
came and go into big hurry and then
finally you had a man named Joseph
mcnich who took that same report
and in his copy which is in the nlm
collection you see in his hand this was
my Bible
and what mcninj did was to turn around
and say I need to make this place more
professional
figure out what best practices are
so we took a young army officer who had
just come back from the Pacific a man
named Frank Bradway Rogers
and said Brad
go to New York get a library degree
when you're done come back here I'll
resign you can be the director and we'll
set this place up
and Brad Rogers became the last director
of the Army Medical Library because and
the Armed Forces medical Army as we came
in 1947 and was actually the first
director of what is now the National
Library of Medicine and among other
things he brought a library professional
with him from Columbia University School
of Library service my alma mater
named Estelle brodman who to this day
um is considered one of the great
bibliographers in the history of
Medicine
and as for Dr Julian one of the little
things that I found out which I never
really stopped to think about so I was
working on this book
Dr Julian was hired in 1944 worked in
Cleveland retired in 1961 she never
worked at the Army Medical Library she
never worked in DC her entire career was
out of the Cleveland branch
so thank you for listening and now I
will introduce my colleague Dr Susan
speaker who will talk about architecture
[Applause]
one of the great things about working at
the library of medicine is that I'm
always always learning new stories about
science and about medicine my work here
has taken me into the history of
molecular biology the history of cardiac
surgery tropical medicine Public Health
military medicine and many other areas
this collaborative history projects that
we're celebrating today expanded what I
know about the library's institutional
history of course you know the people
the organizations changing structures
the budgets things like that but it was
the architectural story that really
intrigued me the most
for one thing learning more about the
architect's design decisions about the
new library building reminded me that
buildings like everything else reflect
the culture and the technological
imitations of their times
what structure is best for a large
Medical Library well when the old red
brick over here on the left
was the new red brick building in 1887
the best structure meant things like
lots of large Windows to light the
reading room to light the offices
because electricity was still in its
infancy in 1887.
it meant things like floors that were
strong enough to support the weight of
all those book Stacks because weak
floors had been a serious problem in the
library's previous home
understandable because that previous
home was Ford's Theater and it wasn't
designed to be a library
it meant a central heating system which
was an innovation in that area era
it also meant toilets conveniently
located in the backyard
and enough space to accommodate oh at
least 20 years worth of collection
growth
this didn't happen by the way they were
bursting at the seams after less than 10
years
perhaps most important it meant a design
and construction materials that would
reduce the chance of fire damage
this was seen as the state of the art in
the late 1880s
in contrast the current building which
opened in 1962 for this building best
structures meant things like
electric light throughout very few
windows
there are most of us who work in the
main building I have to say
come down with a serious case of window
Envy when we talk to people who work in
buildings that actually have Windows
because we have very very few
um
more a little more on that later
it had lots of elevators it had not only
Central Heating but central air
conditioning which was
kind of a coming thing in the early 60s
I think and it had indoor restrooms hey
like its predecessor it was intended to
accommodate at least 20 years of growth
they were bursting at the seams after
about five years I think it didn't take
very long at all this seems to be the
nature of of libraries until we kind of
Hit the digital age
and like its predecessor it was built to
reduce fire risk
but just as important for these times it
was designed to protect the collections
the staff and the patrons
from Bomb Blast shocks
remember this was the middle of the Cold
War and the possibility of nuclear
attacks were looming large for an awful
lot of people
so first of all the collection materials
would be located very safely in three
Subterranean levels
The Architects and the engineers who
worked on this project believed that
shock resistance would best be achieved
by using design and materials that could
equalize the pressure across the
surfaces and on the inside and outside
of the walls and Floors
um at least this was the theory
so the floors needed to be extra thick
and strong the exterior walls were built
with these these narrow channels you can
see them on the bottom photo over there
the uh the slots from top to bottom
um
these were features to absorb shock
um
as you know if you've been in the
building or you work in the building
um
those those little depressions there
bump out and there is glass at right
angles to the walls that's the kind of
Windows we have on the first floor of
the library
and the idea was that um
if there was a Bomb Blast shock the
windows would blow out sideways
dispersing glass along the walls instead
of inward into the reading room and
showering the people there hopefully
those people would be well below ground
down in the stacks where they might be
safe
um
and also work to equalize the pressure
on the inside and the outside
um
it didn't have to be Glass by the way
one of the Architects commented in his
summary of of how the design and the
building process worked that um
you know it's perfectly practical to be
entirely dependent upon artificial light
and ventilation
which was the going thing in the 1960s I
guess but some people like to have an
opportunity to look out once in a while
and it is convenient when it is time to
go home to know whether it is raining
outside
foreign
thank you Mr Killam
um the central rotunda area of the
building although it was an organizing
concept because the card catalog was
centrally located in that area where we
now have exhibitions
um it was imagined that the the staff
offices would sort of radiate out from
that Center because everybody was busy
you know listing and cataloging and
accessing records and things and that
was sort of the the big brain of of the
institution right there in the middle
um and it was also an aesthetic feature
you know a a nice rotunda area with
light coming in above is is sort of a
nice thing to have in a building
um but that too was designed partly as a
pressure release feature for the
building as the architect explained it
if there was a Bomb Blast force would be
conducted along the first floor
somehow and the pressure would be able
to sort of travel up and out through the
Rotunda
um
kind of hard to picture that but that's
what he said
um and it all sounds great doesn't it
doesn't that sound really physicsy and
space agey and just like wow they were
really thinking about this but I shared
I shared this story with a very good
friend of mine who has been an aerospace
engineer for like a million years and he
gave me a short lecture about how shock
waves work apparently at certain
magnitudes error waves start to act more
like fluid and the mechanics that you
have to start calculating become
considerably different
it's apparently quite difficult to
predict what
a given blast will do to a given
structure without actually bombing that
structure
and keep in mind that in this era they
didn't have computer modeling to do
these predictions with
um you know they were doing it mostly
with guesswork and slide rules and a few
demonstrations that they were doing out
west with some of these little potemkin
Villages that you've probably seen
pictures of or films of
it's really really hard even now
he said to figure out what the effect is
going to be so if you can't figure out
what the effect is going to be how can
you really really prepare
um he also commented that these these
vertical slots in the wall and the
you know pressure release through the
Rotunda opening probably would not have
helped very much in terms of releasing
the pressure or keeping it from crushing
the building
at the time in fact he said it would
have been better to put dimples in the
outer wall like a golf ball in a little
little depressions like that apparently
those kinds of shapes dispel air
pressure much better than some of these
other ideas which is why golf balls
still have dimples in them it helps them
fly better apparently
um
there was one planned bomb resistant
feature that might have actually helped
although not in the way that they attend
intended it to
they wanted to put a sort of dry moat
with an embankment of Earth around the
building and the architect talks about a
very complicated system little louvers
right at ground level that the library
staff could kind of open and close when
they knew that the blast was imminent I
guess I mean I don't know how you do
this but
you know and this would equalize the
pressure between the external and the
internal so that
um again you could avoid some of the
structural damage
um my aerospace engineer friend said
that actually that that Earthworks idea
was a pretty good one because the earth
works all by itself probably would have
helped deflect a good bit of the the
pressure wave if it came
so maybe we should have gone with the
golf ball Decor I don't know
um it's probably impossible for me to
talk about the Cold War architecture and
the bomber resistance features of
building 38 without saying a few words
about the legend that most nlm staff
have heard
in some form or other regarding the
building's bomb resistant design the
version that I heard when I first got
here 17 years ago was that the building
was designed so that in the event of a
nuclear attack the walls would sort of
flap down like
flaps on a cardboard box and seal all of
the precious collections down in the
these Subterranean levels
um and indeed the the nlm was fitted out
as a bomb shelter for many years there
were storage rooms down in the basement
levels with all kinds of supplies in
them and I think also some bathrooms and
showers
other things that have long since been
eaten up for storage space and stack
space and Office Space
[Music]
but the idea of the walls falling in
really puzzled me even the first time I
heard it because if you look at the
building in uh
in aerial view oh where's the cliff
right here okay
there we go
lower left there if you look at that
aerial view it's very clear that the
walls would would have to be much much
taller to flip down and cover up
the ground floor of the building right I
mean it's just it wouldn't work
um
and Walter killum the lead architect for
this project wrote a nice little account
of the design and the building of the
library which was published in the July
1961 issue of the bulletin of the
medical Library Association
which talks in great detail about how
this all was done and he doesn't say
anything at all about the walls flopping
down to seal in the collections and I
sort of think he might have done that
because it would have been an
extraordinary structural Challenge and
very unusual even even for those times
and and why would they need to flop down
because as Kilim also pointed out
um if the building got hit by a big
massive nuclear shock wave the roof
would probably go first boom and that
would do the job of sealing things in
um the legends
don't say much about what would happen
to the people in the event of the
nuclear attack I guess the idea was that
everybody would hear the air raid sirens
and Scuttle downstairs and
um
weep over the fact that the incanabula
collection was actually above ground
because it would be toast
um there is is nothing about
um whether there's special ventilation
for people hiding in the basement
there's nothing about whether there's a
secret Subterranean Escape tunnel for
people hiding in the basement
I'm guessing that with enough food and
water and bathrooms that people could
hang out there until they were dug out
we hope
but in any case
I'd really like to learn more about how
these structural ideas were were
conceived and debated and negotiated I'm
not an architectural historian at all
but but I find it fascinating The
Architects from O'Connor and killum that
did the building are not around anymore
and
um
we don't have much about that part of
the process in the nlm collection proper
but I'm hoping that perhaps someday one
of us can pursue the story further as
Ken said if we don't do it ourselves
perhaps we can inspire
some budding scholar to take up the the
task
um
to wrap up I have to say that together
with with learning about the Cold War
architectural design I also really
enjoyed discovering more about that odd
little cap on the roof of the library
which has always always reminded me of
the Jetsons cartoons from the 1960s you
know that
very futuristic looking looking design
and it turns out that the Architects
thought at first of just putting a
regular Dome over that that rotunda area
that would have been the usual practice
but they decided to do something a
little more modern looking and so they
used a form pioneered by Spanish Mexican
architect Felix Candela
which uses
um
plain old two by fours oddly enough they
don't even get shaped they're just put
end to end in in a framework and you you
spray a thin concrete shell over that
and it turns out that these are much
lighter than standard domes which is
kind of nice for the Integrity of the
building and as an added bonus it was
less expensive to construct as well and
the budget minders always appreciate
that
but the best thing was that I found out
what it's actually called it's not a
pagoda roof it's not a judson's hat it's
called
a hyperbolic paraboloid
and now you know
thanks so much for joining us
[Applause]
thank you Susan so my colleagues and I
are going to gather together at our
table here in lipset Auditorium for a q
a you're welcome to ask us any questions
about the work we did for the book or
otherwise if you're here in lipsit
please would you proceed to one of the
two microphones in the uh along the
stairwells very carefully and if you are
watching remotely you can email me your
question
jeffrey.reznick r e z n i c k nih.gov or
if you're following on Twitter the
hashtag is nlm his talk and I'm happy to
say we have two questions via Twitter
already and I'm going to join you at the
table in a moment but I'm going to share
these questions right now
one of the questions we've got is uh
with all of the images available how did
we decide on the best or more
appropriate or most appropriate for
inclusion and related to that is during
the research for the book did we uncover
anything surprising about the nlm
so why don't we take the latter question
first what did we and what did we just
what did we discover uh anything
surprising about the nlm
Susan you want to go first and I'll join
you and we can proceed
use your microphone
um
well a lot of what I discovered was was
in the talk that
um there there had been
some some actual real planning for some
of these bomb resistant features
um and the architect had written about
it which was something that I hadn't
come across before and
um
it was also surprising that we we didn't
have more of that that process
documentation within our collection
frankly
we did have something you know
concerning the the initial
um
debates about where to put the library
for example and those kinds of
negotiations but as far as the actual
building process went and I'm sure there
must have been
a lot of negotiations before the
contract was was finally approved and
you know things actually started moving
we I didn't find I can't say we don't
have it what I can say is I didn't find
it
okay
all right so uh you know it's a it's a
very good question you know the
the number of things that you learn in
doing a project like this uh it's uh you
know even if you already know a lot of
the history going in uh they're it seems
like every uh every rock that you turn
over there's something that you didn't
know
um from little things like
again I mentioned in as I was talking
about the you know my my quest to find
that origin document that 1836 document
that we didn't have and I couldn't
understand why we didn't have that in
the first place that seemed like
something that should have been part of
our collection and it is now but um
learning about the the circumstances
around that document the fact that
Joseph Lovell who had been the Surgeon
General up until just about a month
prior to that uh happened to die of
pneumonia right before that budget
request was due so the the man who ended
up submitting that was just an assistant
surgeon who happened to be working in DC
at the time he wasn't even a senior
officer he was a kind of a very Junior
guy who happened to be working there and
they kind of somebody grabbed him and
said okay you're in charge until we pick
somebody else
and that was Benjamin King and so he was
only the acting Surgeon General for
about a month and a half but during that
brief period uh it was time to submit
the the budget request for the following
year and he tacked on there that 150
bucks for books and that you know that
was the first time that it happened so
it was interesting the circumstances
that that led to really
establishing the the library planting
The Siege with those first few books
that became the library it was just an
interesting happenstance that occurred
sleep and one of the things that I ran
into is that in the mid-1930s there was
a plan for a building to replace the red
brick it was to be near the Library of
Congress I think where the Folger
Shakespeare Library is now I'm not sure
about that because it's all very vague
there's one architect's rendering which
is repeated in the American Library
Association report and looks very much
like a um
a Jefferson rather a Lincoln Memorial
sort of building you know columns and
things but as far as I know there was
nothing ever done except for that
external drawing no internal plans and
never a budget to go further
hmm
um I'll I'll address the two questions
of in terms of what I learned and and
the challenge of choosing certain images
over others
um so there are in our archives uh not
surprisingly many many more images than
those that which appear in the book and
we were I'll say helpfully constrained
by The Format of the series uh the
images of America series Arcadia press
has developed a very popular series that
has hundreds of titles and the way that
they've achieved the success is by
having a a a very distinct format by
which they ask authors and editors to
conform to tell their story so this is a
great way to have a very successful
series but for organizations like ours
in history like ours which has a lot of
and others of course there's a lot of
avenues you can go down to to tell tell
the stories and and many more items in
the collection to share so
um an example of our choosing certain
images over others we
he had many pictures of Staff doing all
types of work particularly during the
the period of the old red brick and this
was work cataloging indexing processing
materials and where we were able to
identify those staff we tried very hard
to include those pictures over others
where we couldn't identify staff we
wanted very much to be able to know and
show the pictures of the people whose
names we knew if only the the surnames
additionally there were images that
there were far more images in certain
categories than we could we could
possibly use in the construction of
building 38 which uh Susan spoke about
as well as our adjacent building 38a
which is the Lister hill national Center
for about technology information which
is shown in the in the video production
uh that you saw at the outset of our
program there were many many more images
of these constructions than we could
possibly show so those that we selected
were a key to convey how the
construction was happening the the third
the image for 38 the image with the
crane the image with the two gentlemen
Atop The Roof those were more
provocative images than say the the
multiplicity of images that show
different angles of the building uh one
or two of those was sufficient and then
these others added could supplement the
story for building 38 38a the Lister
Hill Center we tried to show those
images that were the most interesting in
terms of how the walls were being
constructed the cooperation among the
workers to erect those those aspects of
the building so we we did curate those
images quite carefully and generally
speaking the Arcadia images of history
images of America books contain anywhere
from 170 to 200 books a 200 uh images
the more images you have in the book the
less uh you're able to tell the story
through the narrative so we had to
strike that balance and I'll confess at
times it was particularly challenging
because we had such a great collection
to draw on
I think the the thing that I learned the
most about this type of project and
about the library is how by curating
these images really carefully
one can can can pull them together in a
way to convey that General history of of
the library we have images and if you
read the book uh and look at the images
you're you're drawn into the spaces by
we have images that show the four
different locations of the library over
the course of 180 years we present those
locations and then we draw you into
those locations with images of those who
worked in in those locations and what
they're doing so the book is literally a
journey in and around and through these
four different locations so if you look
at it that way
um the the thing that I learned was that
by looking at this series of images we
have you can really tell that story it
takes some time it takes a lot of
research that you can guide The Reader
through these spaces in a really
creative way
so we have one question here yes sir
uh excellent presentation and a very
nice book thank you so much for your
work thank you uh just a quick
suggestion perhaps a separate online
file of some of those second pictures
that we could take a look at if that's
possible thank you right no that's an
excellent point uh we were speaking with
a colleague of ours at the library and I
was sharing with her that the very fact
uh that we have many more images than
than are available in the book and we've
talked a little bit about some
additional posts on our blog circulating
now that would allow us to use those
particular images and let me share
beginning this week we are beginning to
serialize this book so there are nine
Parts representing the nine sections of
the book The Eight chapters in the
introduction the first part appeared
earlier this week the second part was
published today that's Ken's chapter and
over the next several weeks you'll see
the serialized content come on our blog
another great way in which we're sharing
this history with with the public and we
thank Arcadia publishing for that
opportunity so we will hopefully do some
some posts after the serialization that
can share some of these other images
Jeff hi uh I congratulate you on the
book for the two comments about the 1962
building one with related to the last
presentation I believe at the same time
that that building was being constructed
the the museum itself and and perhaps
also the Armed Force Institute of
pathology
were having buildings built on the
Walter Reed grounds and also they were
very concerned about bomb shelter and I
believe that one or both of them had
walls many feet thick especially
pointing downtown as
um as bomb and so that there are
similarities in the design con aspects
of the two building of the two buildings
I don't know if you've gone into that
yeah I I didn't but it would be
one thing that I that I thought might be
[Music]
might be check you know what kind of
building programs we were doing you know
federal government at that time and how
many similarities there were how many
buildings do we actually have in this
area that are cold war already
but you know especially on the Walter
Reed grounds that they were very
concerned with that and the the second
point I would make in going through the
building I I was very surprised not to
find a discussion of Luther Terry and
the surgeon general's report of 1964
because I think that alone probably
Justified the cost of building the 1962
building my understanding is that uh Dr
Terry was able to commandeer several
rooms in the basement of building 38 set
up a staff independent of NIH and the
rest of the Public Health Service and
research using the facilities of the
library the true story of smoking and
health and issue his report and it would
have been much much more difficult if
the building had not been available and
they did not have access both to the
space and to the uh the collections of
the library and I was very surprised
that you did not have a significant
section which I think is one of the
Great accomplishments of the library of
medicine is history well
well the stories
um
Dr Terry was actually very lucky that he
he was able to assemble his team when he
did because if he'd waited another
couple of years they they wouldn't have
had enough space for them
so in response to that very good
question uh and I'll Echo uh what Susan
said about needing to make very certain
decisions about what to include or
exclude from the book
um I will confess that at one point in
time as we were developing the research
for the book that was part of the
narrative and one of the tough decisions
we needed to make was to what extent
given that this is a Visual History to
what extent could we find images of that
very important chapter in the library's
history and this so this was a recurring
theme we had to ask ourselves to what
extent were their images left by our
predecessors taken and left by our
predecessors preserved in the
collections of these really important
moments and curiously there were very
few if any images of that important
chapter of of the library they're
certainly the report and at one point we
were going to include it but it was not
a particularly good quality image and
that's no fault of anybody's in terms of
digitization it just the the quality of
the original report was not visually
compelling and as important as it was
from a Content perspective we had to
strike the balance of of you know
choices of images in in the book so
um interestingly we did find one photo
of the proceedings but it was a copy it
was a photo in a digitized publication
that was itself a photocopy
where that original photo exists we
didn't weren't able to find it so
absolutely acknowledged but again this
was a decision we needed to make to what
extent could we could we illustrate
these particular chapters so now with
regard to the to the museum the national
museum of health and Medicine which I
had the privilege of serving uh there's
their senior curator for a couple of
years uh well over a decade ago more
than that
um I I will say that the inclusion of
the Army Medical Museum and the images
of the national the image of the
national museum of health and Medicine
photographed by by Steve Greenberg that
was included in The Narrative of the
book largely from my own uh my own wish
to do that because of the relationship
between the Army Medical Library the
Army Medical Museum and I had the
privilege of serving there and I think I
may be the only person in at least post
World War II to have served both at the
former Army Medical Library
National Library medicine and the former
Army Medical Museum National Museum of
health and medicine so I felt it
important that
um that be part of the story as well
because many
among the questions that I often receive
is well isn't that the wasn't that old
red brick the museum no no it was
actually housed the Army Medical Library
as well well what happened to the museum
and so thus it was relocated to Walter
Reed in the building that you're
referring to and I'll also add that
there's a post on our blog circulating
Now co-authored by Ken and myself about
a staff visit we made to the museum a
couple of years ago and we drew partly
on that blog post to talk about the the
museum in our book and I do encourage
you all to go to the now the new
national museum of health and Medicine
which is located in Forest Glen in in a
new building uh post uh the period that
they were at the original Walter Reed
campus so great institution and great
institution comparable to our National
Library of Medicine so thank you for
your question
yes thank you for sharing your stories
and this book is really interesting I
love hearing about the history of the
nlm and its different iterations so
you've kind of addressed this in some
ways but now that you have this book you
have all these ideas what's the future
what's the next step what what will you
do next what will be the next big
project and and then to follow up on
that when you're talking about having
images
to present to talk about to show the
history
do you have um can you comment on now
the digital age and photography in the
digital age and how you can represent
that in future projects
so um with regard to your thank you very
much for both questions with regard to
your latter question about photography
in the digital age I'm going to defer to
Steve Greenberg who is a photographer
and is much better suited than I am to
address that in terms of future projects
I'll talk about that perhaps after Steve
addresses that question
thanks Jeff um
if I had the time I could do a book of
this length just on the Army's response
to World War II and the Army Medical
libraries response and there would be
pictures to support that
in terms of taking some of the pictures
and digitizing them
you can do so much more
than you could to make the pictures more
presentable but on the other hand you
don't want to polish them up to the
point where the fact that they were once
upon a time
silver halide images so some of the
scratches really kind of need to to be
there and one of the few limitations
that I bumped into is that the pictures
needed to be in black and white
and so there were some pictures that I
converted
from color to black and white to keep
the tonality the way I would want it to
be to represent it better which is way
easier to do digitally than it was in
darkroom days but at least we were not
faced with the opposite
we didn't have to colorize anything
which was far as nice but the um
at one level we've only scratched the
surface of what we just have in our own
collection if we continue to look
elsewhere
to the museum to the National Archives
to other institutions there are all
sorts of stories that we could tell
so regarding uh what's next the you know
the future uh you know follow-on
projects to this as I mentioned that
and Steve said we scratched the surface
with the images we scratched the surface
with with everything in this book it it
is uh you know it's kind of an
introductory book it's a light read it's
intended to be that way uh we don't go
into uh really great depth on a lot of
issues and and there are I mean
dozens of aspects of just the chapters
that I worked on
um
it could could be blown out into almost
full-length books or certainly a
presentation so the the thing that I
mentioned in in my talk
about the meteorological reports I think
that's really timely and a really
fascinating uh
and and I think you know kind of
understudied
um
part of our our history and part of uh
the Army Medical Department's history
for that matter the the library of
course belonged to the Army Medical
Department at the time and so
the fact that somebody in that time
frame was thinking the way that Joseph
Lovell was thinking and thinking about
climate change and and things at that at
that level and at that time is really
interesting and I think really ripe for
somebody to probe that deeper and I
don't know if that's going to be me
because I do actually have a full-time
job but um uh you know I think there's
uh there's there's a lot of interesting
work to be done in in that area and
countless others throughout the book
so I appreciate those those responses
very much and I agree with them in terms
of what's next I think the for the
foremost thing is to continue to share
this book as publicly and widely as
possible to encourage a wide readership
to to look at it and to become
interested in what our institution has
to offer both historically and in terms
of its contemporary mission
as Ken said there are dozens of aspects
of the book that can be blown out into
into full books um uh following on his
comments I'll share that in in the book
there's an image of the first uh volume
of the official medical history of world
war one uh which was put together by the
Army Medical Library and and that series
of 15 volumes and it was based itself on
the medical and surgical history of the
war of the Rebellion which was a
generation earlier in the published in
the 1870s and then moving forward there
was an official history of the Army
Medical Department of World War II uh
the the efforts to pull together these
uh Publications
uh those stories could be told as well
and and they resonate with the the
mission of the library today in terms of
data collection in terms of data
curation in terms of data preservation
these were uh you know precedence to
what we're doing today in in many ways
um large-scale efforts by experts of
various disciplines to gather data
process it curate it
present it and publish it to document a
particular period of time uh whether it
was a Civil War World War One or World
War II and that's a story in of itself
each of those and then together they
represent a really interesting aspect of
the history of the library in terms of
data which we are really talking at
Great length about today in in our
strategic planning process and certainly
the future of the library so
we have another question
so I have two questions one's very
specific and one's a bit more General so
the specific question is the security
features that are in the building now
that are in the Cold War era building
did they talk about those publicly was
that something that they touted as part
of this exciting new building that's
going in in Bethesda or is that all
something that
um uh you found out people found out
about later that's a really good
question when I was when actually Jeff
and I worked on that chapter together we
we did search around for contemporary
news coverage because we thought why
would they be paying attention to this
building it's so unusual
um
I I didn't really find much
and nobody talked about the the Cold War
features and even at NIH you know we we
went through the NIH record and there
were occasional articles you know about
the construction with nice little
pictures and a a comment about the the
hyperbolic paraboloid top which I think
did
described it approvingly as having zing
[Laughter]
which really made me laugh
um
I mean it got attention but
I didn't find any any mention at all of
the fact that this was a especially
secure
well-designed you know in intended to
you know deal with nuclear shock waves
I I and that's a good question because I
don't understand why nobody would have
played that up
and then my more general question is
probably for all of you one of the
things that I think is so interesting
about the libraries that it had very
different institutional homes being in
the military and then now being part of
the NIH and I'm wondering if in your
research you came across any images or
documents or accounts that speak to the
ways in which the institutional home can
shape the culture and if there was
anything about kind of disentangling
from the army that came through as
either particularly fraught or
complicated that kind of thing
the gentleman I mentioned earlier Brad
Rogers who was the last army officer and
who
um
sort of oversaw the the transfer
there's an oral history which was
actually done by the medical Library
Association there's also an oral history
of Estelle brodman who was basically
head of reference at the time and Rogers
brought her from from the University to
work here are very deeply involved in
this and there are also sources from
outside
the library places like the New York
Academy of Medicine and the other major
medical libraries of the time saying hey
if you're going to be a National Library
of Medicine here's what we expect you to
do and I think the most famous fruits of
that particular moment
are the establishment of the Regional
Medical Library system and one of the
you see in that lovely video one of the
original maps of the rml districts that
we would act not as a leader in the
military sense but a leader in the
intellectual sense of giving a point of
focus and also an infra Library loan
system that was unique then is unique
now to get things to people without the
normal restrictions of you need to know
exactly where it is and the dockline
system still exists and allows the
fastest response possible for people who
need an infant Library loan request for
a patient who may be literally bleeding
on the table and you see that in
correspondence in and out
and in the oral histories we have which
are partially our work but also done by
the medical Library association's oral
history committee and their papers are
in fact stored at nlm
no please
so you mentioned the the military
culture uh and whether there was a
difference one thing that that came out
uh in the research of this book and it
was actually I think in Anne rothfeld's
chapter was that
when this was the military you know the
Army Medical Library was staffed by Army
personnel and so in in times of War army
Personnel often have better things or
other things to do instead of working at
a library so they got pulled away the
Army you know the active duty soldiers
were called off to World War one and
again to World War II but um when they
were called off to World War One the
impact of that was that they were
backfilled by women primarily and so
this was the first time in the history
of the library that the staff was
predominantly filled with women who
worked as Librarians and technicians and
did everything in the library and so
that that was kind of a turning point
and and uh some of the the women who
came in both you know as uh
Physicians who brought their medical
expertise to you know work in the the
indexing and the cataloging
um
and women who had expertise as
Librarians really
kind of turned or started the Turning of
the library from this Army institution
into a real professional library and it
made a huge difference and you know that
so that that was a point when I think
the the military culture uh started to
give way to a more professional civilian
culture and and really the library
started to focus on what it could be and
and started to grow into the institution
that it eventually became
okay thank you okay two points related
to the moving of the library to
Cleveland at the National Gallery of
author pictures of the loading of the
paintings of the National Gallery onto
local moving vans to be brought to the
Bookworm mansion in in North Carolina I
was wondering whether other institutions
like the Library of Congress were also
moved and the converse of that is was
the building the red old red brick
building used for other War related
activities when the library was not
there during the war
and in fact as the original NIH building
sound at Navy Hill were used during the
war
the red brick wasn't emptied the staff
continued to work there it was only the
items that were seen as being culturally
important so it was Dr free up space
then
um well there was a certain amount of
that as well because the library was
overfilled in fact the library began
microfilming its collection very early
on in the 1930s not to provide a backup
but to provide space but Dr Jones and
his staff and core functions like the
index Medicus the the indexing of
medical literature remained and
um
in DC when
when the books came back those books
that had been in Cleveland became the
core of what is now the history of
medicine division so only the older
books went out and in fact one person
from
DC staff went to Cleveland the rest were
people were hired on the spot I
mentioned Arthur schulian because she's
the most famous but everybody else was
hired out there including John eschman
the um the book binder
so the red brick was not emptied they
simply took that stuff and I'm sure that
there were other offices in there all
sorts of things were in and out of the
red brick wasn't a certain General's
office Army surge General's office in
the red brick for a while I kind of I
kind of think it was
um and so was the pension office right
that's right so um you know it's wartime
in the empty office isn't going to be
empty for very long
so we're nearly to the end of our
program but there's one more question
that we received that I'd appreciated if
we could address because it's a really
important one during the preparation of
our book what did we learn what did we
learn anything that differed from our
earlier histories
I I have a if I can answer that quickly
so one thing that I felt was very
different than the seminal history of
the library which is Windham miles
history going up to 1982 which was
published in 1982. uh that's very much
an Institutional history now our book is
too but uh miles it differs from Miles
book in two ways first it's ours is
Illustrated and miles is only mildly
Illustrated but it's also miles is far
too often written in the passive voice
and personally as a historian I always
try to write as we all do all good
writers do try to write in the active
voice and give agency to the narrative
give agency to the actions that are that
are being written about and I felt
really strongly that this book not only
needed to be engaging and for the
general audience but give agency to the
generations of individuals who worked at
the library rather than say the library
did X Y and Z it certainly did but more
than that it was the leaders of the
library who who led the staff and the
staff the expertise of the staff who
drove the library to achieve certain
things over the course of its history
and I felt that this book differed
fundamentally because it gave agency to
the staff it gave them a voice and it
gave them it put faces on on our
predecessors and and also dedicating the
book to the staff today the staff passed
and the staff in the future was a
gesture toward the agency given to these
public servants of which we all are
um in the work that that has been done
what's done today and what we've done in
the future so so I addressed that
Ken please
so I I would add to that that the the
the method that we took in in
researching this book uh kind of
building on the image collection and and
finding images that could tell the story
uh meant that we necessarily had to tell
a different story
um and so I think what we what we
uncovered in our research for this book
is is quite different from
the more traditional scholarly history
that window miles did because
the the the directions that we went were
really kind of
laid out for us and guided by those
images and so some of the things that
that came out that you don't find really
highlighted in in Miles book are things
like the diversity of the step you know
when you're pulling up these images and
you're looking at at uh
the indexing staff in 1948 and
if you if you are just reading about the
indexing staff and it just you know even
if names are listed or something you
don't know what that what that group of
people looks like you don't know who's
who's involved there and when you see
the images of it and you see that hey
you know this is really a dynamic and
diverse and eclectic group of people
it it highlights where the strength of
the library came from in those times and
I think that those are things that are
are lost in just a purely text based
research so I think that's that's
something that really uh struck me as we
did this uh did the research and
particularly working with Jeff to go
through and edit and select those images
because there were so many that we
weren't able to choose but you know
every one of those images still told a
story and the the stories are are vastly
uh
hmm
not contradictory they're different but
they're complementary to what we had
read in in Miles book
I learned anything new because I'd spent
a lot of time going through the history
of the library anyway but I was reminded
of a few things
and some of them were the you know we
have a few very famous directors who
were here for a long time and you have
people like Jones who's not often
remembered as a great figure in the
library about who really did an awful
lot with very little and there's certain
poignancy to him being asked to stay on
past retirement
and there's another
thing that I I knew but I was reminded
you know we we all know who the longest
serving directors of the library were
but we tend to forget the man who had
the shortest tenure as director of the
Army Medical Library he was given the
job he was already ill with what turned
out to be peritonitis and died before he
actually ever sat in the office as
director of the library and his name was
Walter Reed
well we're at our time and I want to
thank everyone here in lipsit for coming
to our program this afternoon thank you
all for your interest in this book and
again to my colleagues here and everyone
who contributed to this publication
around our institution I want to thank
again Dr Patricia Brennan for her
introductory remarks and welcoming all
of us and supporting this project and to
all of you watching remotely thank you
very much and all of you who I hope will
watch this archive video cast in the
future thank you for your support your
interest and we hope you enjoy this book
and add it to many future summer reading
lists thank you
[Applause]